[Music]
in art preservation news yes
submitted my proof pointed pointing the
video I sure bro point proven
but then he said prove pointed tattoo
artists wife plans to remove her
husband's skin to preserve his body art
this isn't the first time I heard
something like this it's the first time
I've heard something like we first
talked about this it's when it was like
this company was launched it's like oh
now you can preserve your skin art when
you die but so now this one it's like
they're actually doing it and it's also
the biggest to date like how many pieces
damn that's crazy
oh save masking have you guys ever
wondered actually not everyone make a
football you know how our skin is kind
of reminds me of like pigskin I wonder
if somebody cooked us if it would
crackle like pork it'll be as delicious
I don't know about delicious pop I want
to I think probably our skins a little
thinner I think oh for sure there's a
biggest [ __ ] man
pork skin it looks like a very very
rough leather also very tasty oh yeah
the people do practice tattooing on pig
skin dump yeah I've heard no this story
is about Chris he very well-known tattoo
artist how come when pigs escape to the
wild and become boars their skin becomes
black and really really furry well
that's gotta be a different type of pig
no it's the same pain same thing wait it
is so is it are we shaving our pigs no
that's just a domesticated pig and then
when it escapes into the wild and it it
just it just takes one generation for
them to be a boar
okay conspiracy bows is on the case yeah
it's dirty and then they grow tusks and
all actually not the same it can't be
the same Pig time-lapse of this thing
that's why all the boars are there
invasive species because they're escaped
farm animals pits can escape they have
the key
they'll stick it in and up open the
gates how did they get out in chicken
run chicken run was the chief that movie
that claymation one that's old school
yeah they got out I'll pick it up I
don't know maybe maybe a tornado came
and broke the
cage and indeed they're able to run into
the forest pigs are more intelligent
than dogs
yeah and they're genetically the very
similar to us yeah so we're like almost
cannibalizing ourselves but it's so good
though I know it's delicious yeah yeah
what just blows my mind is how quick
they turn into boars yeah like it's like
their domestication was to be pretty
recent then right for them to just
revert back that fast or they're just
that like intelligence I need to see a
time-lapse of this thing yeah it's nuts
cuz when you look at a boar and you look
at like a pig
it's so [ __ ] different almost like
that you all want a wolf I mean I could
understand if it's like you know how I
get the dude doesn't like shave his face
or clean up or anything for a few weeks
then like you know it starts so he
starts to look like a totally different
person I could understand if we had pig
upkeep like are we shaving the pigs are
we bathing I don't know about that but I
have a feeling that we don't but what
trips me out is how does it turn from a
white guy to a black guy in one
generation hip hop hip hop hip hop in
the forest they can listen to hip hop
and then they get crazy
alright so we're talking about Chris
here tattoo artist from Canada he died
in his sleep recently that's a nice way
to go yeah his wife Cheryl will be
preserving his arts through different
companies he looks like a pastor not a
tattoo artist yes Cheryl is well I
thought that was a big ass time Chris is
he gonna taxidermy to him no so what
they're doing is that they're removing
seven pieces from his body
that's a nice fox I'm missing some
photos one second even his own pieces
are really intricate too yeah I always
wonder like when you're a really good
barber or really good tattoo artist and
you're better than any everyone else do
you get a haircut or a tattoo from
someone else guys so this gun focus
sucks ass would you guys get another
tattoo I would but it takes me a long
time to figure out what I want so maybe
when I'm 70 I forgot I have tattoos
yeah Africa do you have tattoos - they
will do so this they preserve the skin
and the art and then they put it in like
dignified that on someone's ball sack or
something how come its shape like that
why would it be about that that's
someone's skin like the front of the
back that's someone's skin that's crazy
that's kid okay I get it that part of
the whole thing is to preserve someone
you love but if you love them how do you
feel about them just being filleted yeah
I'd rather just have a picture taken and
then dude that's crazy Morel Chris's
work that's crazy-looking that just
looks like a stencil so the people that
are behind it I would just want a hand
called save my ink forever how about a
hand like this and then like you cut
that head off taxidermy the hand right
and then you get the rest of the body
like you know paint it on the wall and
then you have that hand sticking out of
the wall so then every day you could
shake hands or high-five or whatever
your husband give you a slap on the ass
in the morning great yeah how would
y'all feel if you were in a relationship
meeting your spouse says to you you know
I really love that tattoo on your arm
when you die I would like to have that
preserve I'll say whatever you want
really like you would be okay with it
yeah because different people have
sentimental value to different things
you wouldn't let them keep a tattoo hell
no and I'm like I have two tattoos and
they're both very embarrassing I don't
want anyone to remember me for that
because you feel like your body still
your body when you die what what are
they yeah what are they she has one on
her bagina that says busy I've a tattoo
on my back that says vicious Wow three
vicious I was 18 was that your alias at
that time I thought that I was a real
tough cookie but in reality it was all a
defense mechanism and I'm a big softy oh
okay yeah I got vicious on my back
what's the other one
I have the word Belial on my arm a Lyle
yeah it's Latin for without a master
later on come to find out it's also a
demon in a Diablo yeah yeah yeah it's
supposed to be Latin for without a
master so I was like nobody tell me what
to do I'm gonna get this and I never got
another tattoo
I'm about to say cuz I because I played
Diablo Diablo - yeah everyone everyone's
like cuz I'm in the gaming industry
everyone's like oh my god isn't that
like the devil and I'm like woah it's
like Latin but like I guess like oh yeah
Joe what stop - if I got two tattoos I
regret it yeah I feel like I relate
because when you choose a tattoo you're
trying to make a statement you're so
serious about it now at my age
I don't give up look I just want good
art yeah cuz I'm like I'm getting my
last day because it's for my mom and my
grandma it's like shut the [ __ ] up
eighteen-year-old Joe you [ __ ] I was
gonna do so many other things
oh I gotta get this piece and I remember
talking to my tattoo artist too like oh
this means this to me like they don't
give a [ __ ] they just wanna [ __ ]
design but it's so important to you and
then like people have this dance like oh
you shouldn't get a tattoo unless it
means something yeah I'm like shut the
[ __ ] up dude that was a phase like yeah
it has to mean stuff like yeah now I'm
so glad I didn't do it oh my walkman
because like the decisions that you make
is so [ __ ] emotional and it's like
it's so meaningful but it doesn't matter
when you lick later on you're like why
did I have to prove myself to anything
do you guys think that tattoos give
gives a guy a sexy factor when I was
like 18 but depends on the type of
tattoos I had the type of guy - if they
have like really good art then I'm like
oh [ __ ] okay okay so yeah you have
really good taste but if you had like
really like if you had like barbed wire
and [ __ ] in your head you're like haha I
picture this talk about that picture
this David Beckham no tattoos he's a
completely different person now really I
only know what his face looks like he's
like he's very model E and that gives
him like this like he has an edge later
doesn't cause extra pizzazz to him
because there's some people - like I see
there let me get their tattoos and I'm
like damn that she did nothing for you
bro but how did that do nothing for you
it's like it's almost like the taxi
doesn't exist
yeah use their personality or something
you know I mean like who they are as a
person maybe get like a dope-ass art
piece but it's like I don't really want
to get a tattoo but the reason why I've
never
because my taste changed so frequently I
like hot just I don't want to get
something and then not like it I did a
tattoo that it only takes ten minutes to
do oh yeah they're there the whole
little minimalist like very skinny
letters things yeah like right now I
would like it but then what if like I
would hate it sure cover it up for sure
it's gonna happen yeah I don't have my
tattoos because they all mean something
yeah that's not like there's nothing
where I would want to put Meeny you
better put a pig on me like it needs
something as in memory
they suck now but it was like me and my
buddy got tattoos at the same time when
we were underage and we shouldn't have
got it but it was such a cool experience
though the artist [ __ ] and in the other
one I tattooed myself so I'm like that
was cool and the bestest tattoo you can
ever get now in three years it's a
shitty tattoo because technology changes
art changes you go find me a [ __ ]
what's called a hipster chef in LA that
doesn't have a [ __ ] cleaver tattoo to
them that's just like a lot of artists
though like if you're in the creative
space it's like it's like a préval yeah
a lot of artists have tattoos means that
tattoos lost its edge yeah yeah so it
just to me it's like a [ __ ] earring
it's a decoration now so I'm like and
it's a hell of a commitment for a four
earring you know what I mean I don't
mind it I think it's cool like I'm glad
that it kind of lost this edge because
now people aren't like judging you based
on my because it was special like when I
was like 18 that's like [ __ ] what is
that oh I can't do math over ten years
ago right um I was I was dating a girl
at the time that had sleeps
that was [ __ ] rare yeah it's still a
girl with two full sleeves that's wild
you know not as much as before though
like ten years like ten years plus that
[ __ ] was like you're either gang related
or you're a [ __ ] bad-ass
so for you it was because it it told you
a story about the person it's also like
you were pretty risky like now it just
means you could take paint for back then
it meant it meant like you are really
outside of society and you were ready to
kind
the new thing for that then now nothing
I feel like it's cauliflower ears yeah
you see this how about Carly fire is
like okay this guy's gonna [ __ ] [ __ ] up
don't [ __ ] with this guy yeah like it
really it really did represent a rebel
or like edge oh no like now it's not
that we live it's not really the rest of
the world has problem I mean yeah it's
still edgy but I think it's lost a lot
of it when I was like 16 like 16 17 18 I
was in the hole like emo kid scene kid
phase so every dude that I dated was
like gauges piercings tattoos kiss me I
didn't care if you had a job I didn't
care if you were a nice person I'm just
like oh you're hot and you're like in my
scene thing or whatever I've dated all
y'all they have they had no money they
had they had a lot of emotional profited
literally like for super towels you
literally just said you're in the emos
exactly but I cannot do tattoos I can't
do alternative anymore because like I've
dated so many of them that I'm like yeah
No No thank you no more no more you turn
into Asian lady
[Music]